[Music]
on this tuesday night ukrainians
preparing for a long fight
the families torn apart by war as
russian forces keep up the assault on
cities and towns
a standing ovation for ukraine's
president as he addresses the british
parliament
we are looking for your help
and prime minister justin trudeau meets
other nato leaders in latvia let him do
what i can recognizing the power and
strength of ukrainian women on this
international women's day why should i
wait until someone will rescue me and in
the running who's joining the federal
conservative leadership race
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
[Applause]
it is all about survival for those who
are living under siege in ukraine this
is mary opal finding basics like water
power and food is getting harder by the
day about two hundred thousand people
have been trapped in this coastal city
for days under russian bombardment
repeated attempts to open a humanitarian
corridor out have failed
good evening and thanks for joining us
others who are able to flee are getting
out the u.n now says 2 million people
have left ukraine in 13 days europe has
not had an exodus like this since the
second world war
and though russia has not made huge
advances in taking over territory it
does keep firing artillery and missiles
at cities
maria abdieva lives in harkev and has
been documenting the russian bombing
putin and his cronies claim they do not
bombard now you would see behind me that
the whole district the whole area is
completely destroyed the houses are in
ruins
in london british parliamentarians
packed into the chamber to hear a
special address by the ukrainian
president who evoked winston churchill's
most defiant speech
we will not
give up and we will not lose
we will fight in the forests in the
fields
on the shores
in the streets
he pleaded for the world to do what
needs to be done to stop russia we have
complete coverage tonight beginning with
mike armstrong in ukraine
this is a painful goodbye a police
officer sending his family away his son
clearly not wanting to leave without him
[Music]
civilians in two parts of ukraine were
able to leave conflict zones tuesday
this is urpin a suburb northwest of kiev
an estimated 10 000 people have crossed
this spot young old and every age in
between leaving their homes behind
this man says there was no power no
water no heat they were cut off from
everything except the shower
even as they left that showing continued
yes yes the bombs are exploding he says
it's intensive
now civilians also left the eastern city
of sumi they boarded buses just hours
after a russian airstrike that local
officials say killed 21 people including
two children
now there were plans to move people out
of the port city of mariupo it didn't
happen the ukrainian government claims
russian troops shelled what was supposed
to be a safe route out it now accuses
russia of holding 300 000 people hostage
in conditions that are getting harder
and harder
the anger
is in mariupol
the soldier urges people to stay united
and not to panic
now in the eastern part of the country
50 000 people a day are passing through
la viv on their way out of ukraine this
man is originally from nigeria his home
in harkiev was destroyed by shelling he
says while he listened to the explosions
from a nearby bunker
the soundings and the vibration is not
it's not good for anyone
scary yeah very scary the vibration is
like you're actually in the bum
but there's something that keeps telling
me that if you can hear it you're still
alive
if you can hear it you're still
alive even among the helpers the
volunteers there is stress the countries
at war and friends and family are in
danger
this woman got her mother out of the
country but stayed to do her part she
says she had plans in life but plans
change
her job and her dreams she says at the
moment aren't important
michael armstrong is with me now from
levive mike so many thousands of people
are leaving their homes because of this
russian aggression
what are their options though what are
people you've talked to saying about
where they're going yeah donna that's
probably the most shocking thing about
talking to people
at the train station they don't know
where they're going every single person
i spoke to today had the same answer i
don't know you know when we travel we
normally have a destination maybe
someone meeting us at the other end
hotel reservations something like that
these people don't have that all they
know is they're heading west and they're
hopefully heading somewhere safer now
what the other thing that they do know
is they can't stay here this city is
full the mayor of la vie says most
people are just passing through but they
have about 200 000 extra people here
right now he says they'll need help from
international aid organizations if more
people come
and they expect more people to come
donna
mike armstrong in la vie ukraine thanks
nato reaffirmed its unity today the
secretary general meeting prime minister
justin trudeau in latvia trudeau
announced canada is extending its
commitment to operation reassurance in
latvia where several hundred canadian
soldiers are stationed abigail beeman is
traveling with the prime minister
getting along well with the canadians
prime minister justin trudeau greets
troops along with leaders from spain
latvia and nato we joke that we're you
know we're actually taking care of a
third of nato right now
540 canadians lead a nato battle group
of 1500 at this base joined by troops
from nine other countries who have to
figure out how to work together it's
been a hard work but honestly if if i
had to say that can we fight
i have no doubts we can actually go and
fight and will they have to fight is the
question canada has been in latvia since
2017 but russia's invasion of ukraine
has demanded attention here with more
canadian troops on the way trudeau was
asked if he'd go to war if russia
encroaches on a centimeter of nato
territory i know i can speak for all
nato members when i say we will all
abide by article 5. an attack on one
member of nato is an attack on all
so we're committed to that by treaty we
are stepping up to send an even stronger
message to
president putin we are here to protect
every inch of allied territory canadians
we spoke with on the base say the
situation in ukraine doesn't change
their day-to-day jobs but it's on their
minds my heart with ukraine
it definitely increases my motivation
and my passion for my role here and i
can see it around the base and
everybody's extremely switched on and
doing their job my heart is with them as
well and
sometimes
as a soldier
we wish we could be there to help
during his visit trudeau announced
canada will be extending its commitment
here set to expire in 2023 canadians
will now be staying with no fixed end
date as the situation evolves abigail
beeman global news adage military base
latvia
the man who is leading his nation's
defense against russia gave an
impassioned plea to the british
parliament today vladimir zelinski
addressed the comments by a video link
quoting shakespeare channeling winston
churchill and laying out the horrors
inflicted on his people by russian
forces crystal gamansing reports
over 50
children have been killed
these are the children that could have
lived
but these people have taken them away
from us the pain of a nation laid bare
as the ukrainian president addresses
politicians far from the front lines we
will not
give up and we will not lose
we will
fight till the end at sea
in the air
we will continue fighting for our land
whatever the cost
[Applause]
paraphrasing winston churchill vladimir
zelinski ended his speech saying glory
to ukraine
glory to britain
[Applause]
he's reminded us that our freedom and
our democracy are invaluable in his
righteous defense i believe he has moved
the hearts of everybody in this house
move the hearts but not the political
needle to back ukraine's plea for a
no-fly zone world leaders have
repeatedly said such a move could lead
to the war spilling beyond ukraine's
borders on monday the uk announced an
additional 295 million dollars canadian
in aid money on top of the weapons
including thousands of anti-tank
missiles it is already supplied in
addition to that historic address to the
house of commons johnson also spent the
day meeting with european leaders
particularly prime ministers from
hungary the czech republic slovakia and
poland we must help the
the people of ukraine and the putin must
fail many of these leaders are hosting
ukrainians fleeing the war poland alone
has seen more than 1.2 million people
cross its borders those talks followed
meetings johnson had with canada and the
netherlands monday
efforts by the uk's prime minister to
coordinate support for a country
fighting for its right to exist
crystal glancing global news
london
more signs today of how the west is
abandoning russia mcdonald's which
opened its first restaurant in moscow in
1990 is suspending operations in russia
other major american brands including
coca-cola starbucks and pepsico quickly
followed suit mcdonald's says it will
temporarily close its 850 restaurants in
russia but will continue to pay the
salaries of its 62 thousand employees
there there's intense pressure on
companies and countries to stop doing
business with russia the u.s has
announced it will stop buying russian
oil and gas the eu which is even more
reliant on russian energy says it's
moving as quickly as possible to phase
it out too but there's a risk russia may
turn off the taps first jackson proskow
reports
the lifeblood of the russian economy is
now the newest front in the war we're
banning all imports of russian oil and
gas and energy
the u.s is the latest country to turn
off the taps to russian oil and gas it
follows the lead of canada and adds
pressure on european nations to do the
same americans have rallied to support
the ukrainian people and made it clear
we will not
be part of subsidizing putin's war
russian imports make up just a small
fraction of energy supplies in north
america but they're king in europe where
governments are less willing and less
able to move away from their dependence
on moscow we can't move overnight but we
can certainly do it and we can do it in
a way that doesn't disrupt supply
the uk says it hopes to stop all russian
oil and gas imports by the end of 2022
the eu wants to cut russian gas imports
by two-thirds before the end of the year
it will take until 2030 to phase out in
full it's hard
bloody hard
but it's possible if we're willing to go
further and faster than we've done
before yet no one knows if it will work
to stop vladimir putin or his war
machine as the russian economy suffers
more and more
as these the the sanctions
they start biting
that's where we need to be watching how
putin responds the response so far has
been to inflict pain on western
consumers the kremlin says it might soon
cut off natural gas supplies to europe
and russia claims that oil prices could
suddenly double without access to its
markets at a time when consumers are
paying record amounts for fuel at the
pumps
that hasn't stopped the newfound resolve
to end the world's dependence on russian
energy as far as i'm concerned gas
prices are irrelevant the only thing
that matters is that we take a stand
long considered a security risk it's now
a moral one as well
jackson prosko global news washington
u.s intelligence agencies estimate
between two and four thousand russian
troops have been killed in the invasion
ukraine says this major general was
among them they say he died outside
harkeev along with other senior officers
vitaly gerasimov was a veteran of
chechnya syria and crimea the
investigative journalism agency
bellingcat has also confirmed his death
and american intelligence agencies
briefed u.s lawmakers today sanctions
and ukrainian resistance they say have
slowed russia's advance but the cia
director says vladimir putin is unlikely
to be deterred i think putin is angry
and frustrated right now he's likely to
double down and try to grind down the
ukrainian military with no regard for
civilian casualties where that leads i
think is is for an ugly next few weeks
washington also says it's documenting
possible war crimes committed by russia
representative i don't know that we have
direct evidence besides what we see on
social media certainly the bombing of
schools and and facilities that are not
associated with iranian ukrainian
military would indicate to me that he's
stepping up right to the line if he
hasn't done so already
the u.n estimates over 400 civilians
have died in ukraine in the last 13 days
a texas man has been convicted on all
charges he faces related to the attack
on the u.s capitol a jury found guy
refit guilty on all five criminal
charges he faced including obstructing
congress and interfering with police
officers he stormed the u.s capitol
while armed with a gun and zip ties on
january 6 20 21. the maximum sentence
the 49 year old faces for the most
severe charge is 20 years he is the
first defendant to go on trial and is
considered a test of the u.s justice
department's ability to tie one person's
actions in the crowd to the broader
attack on capitol hill
the federal conservatives quest to find
a new leader coming up the newest
contenders joining the race
tory mp leslie lewis is making a second
run at the leadership of the
conservative party of canada the
ontario-based lawyer was a relative
unknown before vying for the
conservative leadership in 2020 she was
the only woman in that race and she
ended up placing third behind aaron
o'toole she is the second person to
announce that she wants the job along
with mp pierre pauliev more people are
expected to join in the coming days
though including former quebec premier
josh charles eric sorenson looks at his
chances at becoming the next tory leader
he was one of the brightest young stars
at a time when the conservative
political universe was at its zenith the
1980s charismatic fluently bilingual and
so highly regarded prime minister brian
mulroney made john charret the youngest
cabinet minister in canadian history as
we say in french
zombie in the 90s cheray became leader
but only after the party had collapsed
bringing about the reform party in the
block quebecois he helped rebuild the
party and many credit his oratory for
lifting the no vote in quebec's
referendum on independence
[Applause]
he would go on to become the premier of
quebec for nine years then seemingly
left politics for good that's really our
responsibility to be that national
political party
now he's back he hinted last week at
what he thinks he can do for the party
broaden its appeal one thing that i
believe to be very important is to have
a national conservative party
that is able to represent every part of
canada he took over the party at a time
when rebuilding and outreach were
required and he went on to become
premier of quebec our second largest
province in canada so he knows how to
campaign he knows how to build it he
knows how to win shariah was the focus
of a corruption investigation during his
days as premier and others suggest he is
yesterday's man not the right choice for
a modern conservative party we have to
repudiate conservatives like jean
charret who have an inferiority complex
and want to always act like liberals in
pursuit of trying to win power others
see it differently we are an inclusive
party we should be a welcoming party
and we should also be looking at all
parts of the country for success in the
next election chade shakes up a
conservative race that many had already
seen as mp pierre polyes to win if we
know anything so far about this
leadership race a pillow fight it is not
going to be a bar room brawl it will
most certainly be if john chade's goal
is to be a conservative with enough
centrist appeal to beat the liberals and
win the country he may first have to
prove he is conservative enough to win
the party eric sorensen global news
ottawa
the more boosters the better ahead the
who's changing advice on vaccines
the world health organization now says
it strongly supports urgent and broad
access to covet 19 booster shots it's a
change from last year when the
organization called for a moratorium on
the shots saying they weren't necessary
and contributed to vaccine inequality
the who says there has since been a
substantial increase in global vaccine
supply making distribution more viable
and it says vaccines are needed to keep
up with the evolving virus
kovid isn't over in china there's a
surge in new cases nearly 500 000 new
infections have been detected in the
past months that's about 80 percent of
all reported cases in the country since
the pandemic began the chinese
government says it must stick with its
policy to aim for zero cases though
rather than attempting to live with the
virus
women in war next celebrating the
strength of ukrainian women on this
international women's day
war changes everything and when it
happens almost overnight as it has in
ukraine everyone men women and children
must immediately adapt on this
international women's day we want to
salute the women of ukraine we knew they
were strong but the power and bravery
they're showing in the face of this
invasion
is stunning to witness heather urix west
has some of their stories
for olga renberg this is a moment of
gut-wrenching relief her mother ludmila
is now safe in edmonton after escaping
the violence of kiev it's a huge relief
so now i have one person less to worry
about but for olga there is guilt as
well and a longing to help her homeland
but i'm doing what i can
honestly i'm praying every second
that they will survive calgary's elena
burden is in poland she met her sister
at the border with ukraine for just a
moment this week long enough for a hug
and a promise
that she would take her eight and
ten-year-old niece and nephew back to
canada where they would be safe my
sister
tanya
so she said i can give you my kids hand
to hand
because i trust you you can take care
about them
but
i will go back to ukraine an impossible
decision facing so many mothers in the
country right now to leave with their
kids or bring them to safety before
returning to fight women are involved in
every
conceivable aspect of this from from the
front lines to to being the refugees
themselves to caring for the refugees
32 year old alana bashinska has become a
soldier as well
in her old life she taught people how to
use makeup now she is defending her city
it's my country it's my cities my here
are my families and my friends
my animals
so why should i wait until someone will
rescue me so alana fights as elena opens
her home and ogre advocates and prays
just three stories in a country with
millions more
heather urex west global news calgary
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm donna friesen we leave you
tonight with some melodies in the
darkness
that's ukrainian violinist vera
litovchenka she's playing in a bomb
shelter in her kiev this performance she
says is dedicated to her late
grandmother she plays to lift the
spirits of those sheltering here and
when her friends react to her posts on
social media she says she knows they're
still alive
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
[Music]